Hello everyone.
My name is Qa to justice and
I'm an engineering program
manager for Google play.
And we're honored and excited to
welcome director of the movie bell,
Amma Asante. Um, everybody
give her a round of,
hi, welcome to Google. Um,
Anna,
thank you so much for your amazing work
and bringing this little known life to
the world. Thank you. Really
appreciate it. So, um, let's play,
let's play the trailer of the film.
Um,
a group of Google or Scott to see
it last night during a screening.
I really enjoy this film.
I'm glad you're here.
And for those that don't know,
I'm dido.
Elizabeth Bell was discovered from an
18th century painting that was done of her
and her cousin. So, um, um, uh,
how did you learn about this painting
and how did it shape your interest in
doing this project? Yeah, so it was
really interesting process for me. Um,
2009 I had come off of the back
of my first movie, a way of life,
which I was lucky enough to win a British
Academy award where, and I had been,
um, working, developing,
writing other projects. Um,
one of them was a Jane Austen
adaptation. Other, uh, yeah, um, um,
adaptive piece called Lady Susan.
And, uh, so I was working with, uh,
with a do, uh, producer,
um, uh, who had, uh, um,
a small company,
which was part of new line cinema.
And I'm doing all my research because
I find that my research is really my
education as how I've become educated in
any kind of way in life and was really
increasingly becoming obsessed with the
woman's position in 18th century England
in particular.
And um,
so 2009 comes along and I am working
on three different projects and the,
the, the, the, the next one is also a
project which is kind of looking at, um,
a mixed race girl living in
Berlin during the 1940s war,
Second World War. So really, again,
looking at the experience of a person
of color in Europe and the Bfi who,
um, are the British film institute. Um,
very much involved in my work and my
career and financing work that I've done
previously. Um, had received an idea,
a project from a producer, my
producer, it turns out Damion Jones,
who had been trying to get a project
about Dido's life off of the ground,
um,
for quite some time now for him.
It had started life with a writer at Hbo,
um,
here in America. And, uh,
they'd gone through development.
It hadn't quite worked.
The project had been dropped.
Damien had bought it to England.
They had continued with, with the
writer and for whatever reason, um,
you know, that said they moved
on. And so they came to me at,
you know, the Bfi said to Damian,
have you sent this postcard to Ama?
Because she is obsessed with the woman's
experience in 18th century England.
She's obsessed with people of color
in European history and she is an
irrepressible romantic and she's just
dying to tell a love story. So, you know,
have you sent this to her too, to see
what she would make of it? And so,
Damian eventually sent me this postcard.
Now,
I'd never seen the portrait
before. Um, but what,
what I was lucky enough
to have experienced, um,
was going to an exhibition in Holland,
which is where I live now,
which chartered the history of black
people in European art from the 14th
century onwards. And it was
the most fascinating, um,
exhibition I've ever been
to. And it really looked to
us from kind of background,
character rent until we came to front
and center and eventually became music
kind of closer to modern day.
But what it showed me was that in the
18th century, we were accessories.
When I say, well, you people
of color were accessories.
So we were there to express the status
of the main Caucasian protagonists in the
painting.
So we were always painted lower down.
We were never looking out or very
rarely looking out at the painter.
We were always looking are,
but the main protagonists without
arm reaching out towards them,
which would draw your eye towards them.
And so when this painting of which
is known as bell impact came to me,
it, um, it came in the context where
I could see it was so different.
There is Dido.
So beautiful.
And I'm happy with this
sparkle in her eye,
looking directly out at the painter.
She's actually painted slightly
higher in the painting and wow,
it's Elizabeth psalm that is reaching
out to her, drawing your eye to her.
And uh,
it was a revelation to me and what I
saw at that point was the opportunity,
if I got it right, to tell a
story that would combine politics,
art and history and race and
with the sub themes of love,
gender, the women's place,
identity, belonging, you know,
all of those, I knew it was
going to have to be a big story.
So that's where it really started for me.
Then it was a process of re research.
Um, and going back to, um, you know,
finding out exactly what kind
of story I would want to tell,
how much of that would have to be drawn,
affection and how much of it would
have to be w need, must be history.
What was it like premiering it at the
Toronto Film Festival after all of that?
It was incredible.
Um,
my first film had been screened
at Toronto Film Festival,
but we were very small
independent British movie.
And whilst bell had been
made as an independent movie,
it British independent movie.
Um, we were, we were, um,
brought by Fox searchlight right
before Toronto, which was great.
And we weren't brought just for,
um, the u s or just for the UK.
We were bought for the world.
We had their might behind us by
the time we came to, to Toronto.
And it was quite a different experience
having a big studio or a studio like Fox
searchlight behind you who was so in love
with the story and so much wanting to
be part of this story and
bringing this story to the world.
So it was an incredible experience of
something like three minute standing
ovation kind. Yeah. More or less.
And I'm just the first time that we
really felt love for the film from people
who had not been involved
with it. Yeah. That's awesome.
So there's an interesting dichotomy.
I'm represented with her name.
So there's Dido, which was what
her British family called her. Yes.
And then there's belt, which
was her mother's name. Yes.
So why did you choose to title the film
bell? Well, in the movie, you know,
um, we, we don't ever see her
mother. We only hear about,
um,
and we're seeing this girl in this world,
which is completely white
apart from Mable. Um,
the maid and I wanted to honor
her mother died, his mother,
I wanted to,
to honor her,
even though she could not be
physically present in the movie.
I wanted it to be spiritually
present within our memories.
And so as she was Maria
Bell, um, and as, uh,
she named her daughter after herself.
I wanted them to name the film after
both of them and, and pay tribute to,
to have mother. Ah, very nice. Very
nice. Yeah. And so how did, um,
how did you connect with Google in Bartow
raw as the lead actress for the film?
Actually it was, uh, it was,
it was a very easy process.
The movie that I had talked to you about
earlier that were set in Germany, um,
which I will shoot in
2015 where hands touch.
Um, Google had actually
originally come to audition for a,
so she'd come in for casting and uh,
this young woman stepped into
the room and her presence,
I was just completely blown away
at that time. So I knew if Gugu um,
quite some time passed and she came over
to America and she was involved in TV
series here and a couple of movies.
She was on Broadway with Jude law
playing or failure to Jude Law's hamlet.
And,
um,
so time passed and both my
producer Damien and I knew of her.
Um, and eventually it was
time to start coasting. We,
we met probably every biracial
actress of the right age in the UK.
And um, yoga was one of those. Um, but,
but Google is smart.
She's very, very smart.
She understood what I wanted
to do with this story.
The kind of journey that I
wanted to put this character on,
which on the surface is very simple.
But actually underneath this very complex,
she understood that I wanted to take
this character from girl to woman with a
political awakening in there,
that it needed to be a sweeping
love story as well as, um,
a story that made us feel the
emotion of the impact of slavery.
Even though we never actually see a slave.
Now, it was very much my wish that, um,
we didn't see slaves,
but we actually had to feel,
we were looking at the laws that supported
slavery and we had to fill the impact
of slavery from that point of view.
And that's because that was
a really important reason,
which was I wanted to prove that you could
put a woman of Color Front and center
of an Osti NASC piece of work at a
traditional British period drama.
And that it would work.
Now obviously in the script that Damien
had been working on previously, um,
you know, which was a very
different world. You know,
daddy was running around with shells
on her ankles and they jumped to Vinay,
has an affair with, with,
uh, with Elizabeth. And, um,
it's, it's, it's, it was good bell and
bad and it was a very different movie.
But for, and in that you
did, you did see slaves,
you did see slaves sort of interludes
with slaves kind of floating on the water.
And it was kind of a reminder that
this is what happened to those over 100
slaves during the Zong case.
But for me,
I wanted to work from a much
more psychological point
of view and really look
at,
well,
for me it was important that if I was
going to tell a movie that was Austin ass,
and that looked at tell society that I
also looked at the world that was there
and
funding that society and the
economy of that society, um, and,
and the trade that was sponsoring that
society and that was the slave trade. So,
um, yeah. So it was very important
for me to keep it Austin asked,
but also make sure that the impact of
slavery and was it important that the
actress be of mixed race that
played the roles. It was very,
very important that she'd be of mixed
race being that have we knew that her
father was white and her father and
her mother was black. It was very,
very important that she
didn't look completely. Uh,
I see completely black.
We come in all different shades,
but it didn't look like both
her mother and father were, um,
100% black or 100% white.
It was important that we could see
that she was at the junction of race.
She is at the junction of status.
She is at the junction of all these
different themes in the story because the
story is really about a woman who comes
to a place where she has to combine all
of these parts of herself, the child of
a slave and the child of an Aristocrat,
the child of a black person and shelter
of a white person, a woman of color.
Growing up in an aristocratic society
and she has to find a way to love all
those parts of ourselves,
bring them together and be okay with it.
So it was very, very important that
she looked the mixture that she,
she absolutely is. Absolutely. Yeah. Okay.
So there's a scene that I thought was
really powerful between Mabel the servant
in London and bill,
um,
when she's combing her hair and she's
struggling to comb her hair and bell
offers to show her how to comb her
hair from starting from the end.
May Bill offers to show bell, I'm sorry.
Yeah, maybe oppositional building.
And so I believe that there
was a significance there
that you wanted to convey
to the audience. Was there? Yeah, there
was, you know, I was thinking about,
um, growing up in a household
of people that love you,
but our learning trying to understand the
right way to love you the way you need
to be loved, but people who don't look
anything like you, what must that be like?
And it brought me to a place where I was
thinking about maternal legacy and the,
the things we take for granted,
the simple things that we take for
granted that our mother passes on to us.
And so I had been thinking
about cooking and you know,
oftentimes it's our mother that teaches
us how to cook the food that comes from
our community and from our
culture. And I thought, well,
Dido wouldn't cook for herself,
so that's really not going to work.
And then I thought, hey, you know,
what is something we do every single day
we have to deal with every single day.
That's like our thing,
a woman thing and very much a woman
of color thing. And it was hair.
And I suddenly thought, you know,
no products, uh, you know, no, no,
no shampoos, no tools, nothing.
Everything geared towards
except for the comb.
Exactly everything geared
towards a Caucasian woman.
And,
and,
and with nobody there to teach you
how to take care of their own health.
No one there that knows, no matter how
much they say, no one there that knows.
And I was thinking about this,
and again,
this was part of me honoring her
mother right the way through the story.
So you never see this black woman,
but she's there very much in the
story and we never forget her.
She talks about her right the way through.
And I thought the other thing was that
I desperately wanted to have another
person of color in the movie, which is
why I created me to be in the movie.
And I wanted to show,
you know,
in the way that I wanted to show that
Elizabeth and Dido Bell have a sisterhood
that comes under a lot of pressure,
but they remain ultimately
essentially connected.
I also wanted to show some connection
between bell and a person of color in the
movie. And, and so this moment comes
in, which, which I find, you know,
for myself, you know, when
I was putting it together,
I found it very hard and sad,
but also uplifting at the same
time. It was such affection. Yes.
With such affection and I,
and I wanted it to be that way.
Now this is part of three mirror scenes.
In actual fact with First
Mirror scene is one,
one in which data was actually
harming herself. You know,
she's very uncomfortable with itself.
The final one is one word.
Data is good with herself. She's
happy. You see a small smile.
She's coming to that place
where she's okay with herself.
And the middle scene is a transition.
It's reflecting the transition that data
is going through and this is off the
mirror when they reflect
off the mirror and, and uh,
Mabel is combing her hair
and you see day day relax.
And she's okay with this being
around this woman of color. She's,
she's relaxed in the kind of
sisterhood that this made offers her.
And of course this made says, my
mom taught me. You see? And, and,
and so this middle scene is representing
a transition that that data was going
through with being okay with a part of
herself that society has made her feel
like it's a burden.
That's awesome.
And in fact it was interesting
in the painting, they don't,
Elizabeth Bell is wearing a turban,
so it gives you sort of maybe a hint that
she didn't have anybody that knew how
to comb her hair. And that's how
they managed that in reality,
how they manage that. Yeah. Yeah,
absolutely. Great. So what was it like?
I'm recreating 18th century England
and where did most of the filming take
place? Yeah, it was a joy
because I knew that I'm a,
I was doing something really traditional
that all of you guys as an audience
would have a shorthand to,
we would all know this world.
You've all seen pride and prejudice and
sense and sensibility and faculty is
wonderful world.
But B,
I knew I was going to be doing something
really different with it by putting
this character in the center of it. So I
loved it. You know, I constantly thought,
you know,
I hadn't had,
I always have a color chart for
every movie that I work on, which,
because I think it creates a harmonious,
a static on the screen. But every,
everything I was working with was knowing
that I was going to have this woman
have a beautiful skin tone on the screen.
So for me,
I wanted to present to you a new
idea of an English rose. You know,
my idea of an English rose, so
you'll see in the picture here, um,
Belize always sort of,
um,
featured often around Rose's.
She's in Rosie colors, you know,
her color scheme is that of,
of, of, of beautiful flowers.
And you know, we, we bill out
the color scheme of the, um,
her entire world really from there.
So each,
each family really has its own color.
So for the Ashford family, they
have this kind of icy, cold,
blue go figure. And, uh,
for bail I wanted her to earn
and the Mansfield family,
I really wanted that sense of it being
regal and Regal and important and
wealthy. So they have goals, you
know, you'll see that, uh, you know,
in the world behind Dido here, it's,
it's gold. Their carriage is gold. Lord.
Mansfield's world is pretty
gold as well, quite often. Um,
so it was great. We filmed
mainly in, um, uh, we,
we filmed the English heritage houses in
London, so we weren't able to film it,
the Real Ken Wood House
because it was under,
it was being refurbished at the time.
So we filmed in two or three houses
that we then had to put together.
I had to have a little
ground where I said,
this is where the staircase is B and this
is where the dining room remove their,
my wonderful,
wonderful production designer
was working with me to,
to, to do that and created
again the beautiful aesthetic
that you see on screen.
Um, we also, so we shut a lot in London.
We shot in central London
where we had to shut, you know,
whole streets and really only very
little of what you see as CGI.
It's real stuff. Yeah.
That you see that um,
we shot in the isle of Man to do
a lot of our exteriors, which, um,
is very green and lush and beautiful.
And we also show an Oxford,
which is actually where, um,
Gugu [inaudible] actress is from.
So it was exciting for her,
was like going home and her art teacher
actually walked by accidentally while we
were filming. It was like, it's that woman
in that outfit you go and barter raw.
Cause I used to teach her,
so I had to kind of take him through all
the barriers and getting through to her.
So yeah. Oh that's awesome
to her. Yeah. Okay.
So now I want to switch up a little bit
and talk about some of the historical
aspects of the film.
Yes.
So most of us in the s are very aware of
America's role in the slave trade. Yes.
But maybe not as familiar
with England and England. Um,
emancipated or I should say
abolish slavery. Yes. Um,
decades before the u s yes. Um, what,
can you tell us more about that
history of the slave trade and um,
and specifically the song massacre,
that's sort of the critical judgment
that happens and is the beginning of the
end of a British, yeah, I guess slave
trade in Persian empire. So, you know,
some of you may know this, but, um,
I know we even a lot of
English people don't know this.
British people don't know this,
which is that Britain was the middle
man when it came to the slave trade.
And whenever I'm speaking,
you know, I have to say we,
and then I have to define which we could,
we would be schizophrenia because
I'm black and I'm British.
So this moment I'm British
British. Okay. Got It.
So what we would do is we were,
we, we were the suppliers.
We,
we were very big in shipping at this
point and we had what you would call the
shipping triangle whereby
we would sell from,
uh,
England to Africa and then
to the Caribbean or the
Americas and then back again.
And no leg of that
journey should be empty.
We should always have goods, which
we could trade. And then, uh,
you know, drop the goods off, pick up
new goods and, and go somewhere else.
So here's how it worked. We
would take whatever, um, uh,
goods good Britain had to offer.
We would load them on the ship,
South Africa exchange.
Those goods with money as well for slaves,
load up the slaves,
then off to the Caribbean or the Americas,
unload the slaves,
pick up cotton, um, spices,
whatever we could get,
and then bring it back to front and sell
it in Britain. So that's what we did.
Now slavery was all a bit too
vulgar to have on British shores.
It was all a bit, it wasn't, you know,
it didn't work for the Genteel society.
So it was,
it was all you guys that had it over
this side of the Atlantic and how the so,
so when I say I wanted to look at the
economy that was holding up this genteel
society that you see on
pride in pride and prejudice,
and then this other period
dramas that come before,
because data was a little bit early
actually. Then Austen's time, this is the,
this is the trade,
this is the shipping trade.
And what I should also tell you is that
the world that you come into you with,
bowel is on the cusp of change.
So whereas the,
the marriage is that where the marriage
of the kind of marriages of the time
were based on status, you're married so
that your family status could grow. Um,
what was happening now was the
love marriage was coming in slowly.
It was starting to Piss, um, society.
It was becoming not acceptable,
but it was on its way to becoming
acceptable and new money was coming in.
And this new money would
be a farmer for instance,
who might gain enough money to buy
Shek o and then he would start on this
triangle that we talk about.
So he would also become,
be involved in the slave trade.
And then suddenly he's making
a lot of money from this.
Suddenly his children are
the child of a wealthy man.
Suddenly they might be,
um,
of interest to someone exactly
who might want to marry them.
So there was a fear of this.
And Lord Mansfield is very representative
of that cusp of change that we're on.
He's got one foot in the now and the
kind of the status quo and rules must be
stuck too.
Let's not break up the chaos that let's
not encourage chaos or break up the
rules.
But then he is conflicted because he has
this other other foot very firmly. And,
um,
being a progressive man in tomorrow,
being a man ahead of his time in those
two areas are conflicting inside him.
That could be 10 movies made about this.
There's an incredible man who,
who chose to raise their,
the way that he did.
So you've got all of that coming in.
Now,
the Zong case comes into
the story because, um,
many people were trying to get into
the shipping trade at this time.
And the man who comes to be the captain,
the captain of the ship that sails on
this terrible journey is actually a doctor
and he has, this is his first
time actually captaining a ship.
Okay. And He, so he gets
on this ship and um,
it doesn't quite know what he's
doing and it's a protracted journey.
The journey is longer than it should be.
So they packed the slaves in,
in the disgusting way. We know that they
would, you know, one on top of each other.
They said that you could
smell a slave ship,
a mile down wind of that because it
was so disgusting and full of disease.
And so you can imagine when this
journey becomes even longer because he's
missing all the points where he should,
he should be stopping
and getting off these,
these slaves are getting more
sick and more sick and more sick.
And what happens is he
decides at a certain point
that he is going to order his
crew to jettison the slaves from the ship.
Um,
because he realizes he will get more
money from the insurance than he will on
the open market for them.
Now you could do that. You,
you could jettison your
cargo, you could jettison, uh,
you know, whatever it was
you were carrying. If,
if you could prove that it was
endangering your ship, right.
So if you could prove that those slaves
was so sick that they were making the
crew sec, if you could prove
there wasn't enough water,
if you could prove there wasn't enough
food, if you could prove that there was,
I don't know,
the ship was tipping and had too much
weight on it and you had to jettison so
that you had enough time to get to land,
whatever, what is clear, what we know.
And what I found out during my re my
side of the research was that they did in
fact pass these eight ports where
they could have stopped and got water.
So this ridiculous argument
that they didn't have enough
water was in fact a lie.
And so, um, there in was his own case.
Now Lord Mansfield was caught between
his peers who were the people who
financially benefited
from the slave trade.
And of course his own moral values.
And even more so his love for his child,
if he pronounced in a way that would,
um,
confirm value to his child.
He was actually,
he was actually sticking a knife into
the lifeblood of the economy of England.
And his and his peers.
But if he found for his peers,
what would he be saying about Dido and
who she is and what she means to him.
What we know about Lord Mansfield
previously is that he had ruled on a case
called the Somerset case in which an
American comes to England where the slave
and the slave at once on English
soil says, I know in England now,
I'm not a slave. You can't make
me a slave and hear the question.
Just as the question in, in the zone
kind of centered on marine insurance law.
The question here really centered
on when you're on English soil,
can American, uh, law prevail?
And Lord Mansfield says, no, it can't.
It can't prevail and therefore the
slave is free and he frees the slaves.
So he had all already kind of ruled
previously in a way that would,
which would direct us towards
the fact that he was, uh,
ahead of his time.
He was a man of great moral,
good moral judgment and value.
But of course,
we still could not know what he might
rule on, on the Zong case. Okay. Very,
very interesting. So, um, all right,
so now we want to take a look at, um,
an argument scene. Yeah.
Between the cousins.
When I saw that scene,
I kept thinking she was going to say,
you're black like they did in
the beginning of the movie,
but she not doesn't, she says
illegitimate, illegitimate.
And I'm wondering was that in the original
script or did you try out different
responses doing filming to find
what was authentic? Yeah, no, no.
I mean I always knew I was never going
to take you there because what I wanted
to do was create a sister ship,
as I say,
assistant head and however that's that
that sister ship was going to have to
address the issues of race and
position and status. At some point.
It was always going to have to do that.
But I knew if I took you there,
you would never come back from it.
With Elizabeth, you would, you would,
you would never,
she should never be in your hearts again.
And also it would destroy everything
that I had done previously in showing you
that, that, that lip, look how to women
of different races can love each other.
So I was never going to take you there.
But what I also wanted to do,
which is something I had always,
there are many,
there are many parallels that I had
wanted to strike with this film.
One is the parallel of, um,
uh, of, uh, when gender,
the woman's place and,
um,
the woman being owned by her husband
versus the slave being owned.
So the idea of ownership,
um,
and the other parallel
that I really wanted to,
to Tinder cap was this
idea that illegitimacy
yeah.
Could be in some circumstances as,
as, as, as, as much of a burden as
being a woman, a woman of color.
It was, and that for people that
were the, exactly. And, and you know,
right up until the 60s, I mean, you know,
people have taught me about
being illegitimate or, and,
and the burden that it kind
of put on them. And so I,
I wanted everybody to understand
this is complex. This is not simple.
There was no race issues without class
issues, without gender issues, without,
you know, all of this stuff
that was overlapping the
whole time. And for a woman,
again at the junction of where I've
placed her at the junction of all these
different paths, and as she
says, I find no, no place, I can,
I can find where I belong.
Um,
then I wanted to show you the
complexity of what they say is, I mean,
what I did have a ball doing is I'm
putting together the dialogue of two girls
arguing in the 18th century.
And what you don't see in that clip is
it what follows is what I call a south
London cast. Um, because um, you know,
bell does puts that right in
no certain terms and you know,
I could never put together that scene
without that south London part of me.
Um, so, and you know, in many
screenings that I've been to,
it gets a huge round of applause.
And when I'm sitting in the screening,
I'm there,
I'm clapping with her even though I
put those words in her mouth because,
because,
because I still feel it at that moment
when she's finding her own and saying, no,
you will not, you will not demean me.
I will not allow you to demean me.
So yes, I mean in so many ways, the
language of the film is so bold, you know,
you get the black, the black at the
beginning of directs very direct.
That's something that I experienced in
my life with my first husband will not
mind me saying that. Um, his
mother, when she first met me,
I was very young in my early
twenties, um, said, oh, she's,
she's quite pretty,
but she's very black,
you know, but she's, she's
black and 10 years old.
And it was still nice dress
on her, but she's, you know,
she's black and you know,
uh,
Miranda Richardson's characters very
much based on that experience and, and,
and that person. And so, yes.
So the language is very bold,
but I wanted to play with the boldness
of the language versus us versus,
and not get it because the whole
scene starts so gently with this,
with this piano playing and this,
this loving sister sisterly conversation
and then goes into this horrible,
ugly place. And I wanted
to draw you in, um,
to the dialogue I'd created there and
draw you into and make you think, oh,
now it's going to be
horrible and disgusting.
But she would never do that to her sister.
Even in this situation.
When she said it,
it felt so much more authentic than
what I was expecting to hear. Yeah.
I was like, that wouldn't
work because they love each
other. They love each other.
Yeah, exactly. Awesome. Okay.
So from what I read some of the history
about Deitel Bella is a bit on Wikipedia
and the BBC sites and um,
and so I learned that
bell's existence was, um,
was discovered by the papers or the wall,
the painting,
and then they discovered more about
her life through the papers at the kin.
What house? And I was wondering,
were there any writings
in bill's hand that you,
that were found that could
speak to her voice? And my God,
I pray that there will be one day I
pray that there will be something.
There was a gentleman named
Hutchinson who came over from America,
um,
and he came over to talk to Lord Mansfield
about the Zong case and wanting to
really lobby Lord, Lord Mansfield
to find against the insurers,
find for the ship owners.
In other words, uh, uh,
to lobby Lord Mansfield to find that it
was okay for you to drown your slaves
because this was going to
have such an impact on savory.
And now he writes in his diary,
and I'm totally paraphrasing here,
but it's easy to find on online,
easy to find on Google, um,
that, uh, he,
he comes to the house and he sits down
and he has a formal dinner with the
family.
And after dinner this negress
comes out as grants and um,
you know,
and,
but she has the entire family wrapped
around her little finger essentially,
and she's walking, oh, I'm at home
around the gardens. And you know, they,
they're treating her, you
know, like one of them and he,
and he's horrified by this.
He's absolutely horrified by this.
And what he says is that I wasn't,
I did want to bring up the
zone with Lord Mansfield,
but I didn't think that that was
quite the right time. In other words,
he knew that they clearly loved
this girl and that, you know,
bringing up issues of, uh, black
people at that particular point and,
and encouraging the men to say that
it would be okay to massacre them.
It was probably not the right time.
So virtually it's elements like that.
It's papers that we can find.
For instance,
we know where she married John Davinia.
Um,
so she married him in Saint
George's church in Hanover Square.
We know that she christened all of
her children in the same church.
So that kind of people who are,
I was able to look at the,
the two wheels that Lord Mansfield
left dido bail money in. And,
um, and to discover also that
not even though, you know,
in the film we portray it, that he,
he isn't sure if he can, he does,
but also that his sister lady Mary
played by Penelope Wilton also leaves her
money. And what that expressed
to me would that did it,
it helped to cement for me
the idea that they loved,
they loved this girl and you know,
she had to teach them the right way
to love her as I've said before,
but they love this girl.
So it was really finding for me,
finding all of this information for
the story that I wanted to tell because
look, there have been
pleased on dido bell before.
There have been short movies of Dido
Bell before you, you know, as I say,
there was this earlier version and it
was me about me as a director of finding
my vision of the story, the story I
wanted to tell. Um, and so it was,
I can only do that through
piecing together my own
history and deciding then how
it should all be sewn together. So,
but no diaries, but there's still time.
There's still never know.
You never know how life is.
So I think we're going to stop now and
take some Q and a from the audience.
Does anybody have,
and there's a mic I guess in the center
here and if I have any questions. Okay.
I'll ask more question while people
come to the mic. Yeah. Okay, great. Um,
I actually saw the next one is a scene
and we'd like to queue this scene, um,
where she's actually having
conversation with John and Divinia Ah,
about her status in life. I love
her. Look the way she looks at him.
Yeah, absolutely. It's a complex
scene. That one. Yeah. I,
that's what I wanted to ask you about.
Could you elaborate on sort of, you know,
her thoughts at that time cause
she's recognizing, you know,
this interesting position,
she's in society where she doesn't have
to marry for money and position well
this is all part of her awakening,
weakening,
really all part of a political awakening
or part of her understanding of who she
is as a woman and where, and a woman
of color in where she fits. Like I say,
I always wanted to strike that parallel
of ownership between the person of
color, um, being owned in the woman
being owned. And I was exploring this,
um,
in my own mind is I do one day as I did
as I do in one day and I was sitting at
my desk and you know,
look,
we're putting to the gather the
story that I wanted to tell and I,
I wanted to express the pressure
of society at that time. The,
I mean it was so much
pressure came from society.
And as I say at the beginning of the
movie Via Lord Mansfield Society has a
habit of casting out even one of its own.
When it has the opportunity,
it was so easy to kind of be cast out
and kind of be blacklisted and be turned
out from society. And I, it was kind of
thinking about this fortunate position of,
of this character and how she's wealthy
and a woman of color at the same time.
And yet she's still desperate to belong.
She still desperate to be like
the other girls who have to marry.
And she's still desperate
for society's endorsement,
which says she, she, she, she,
she only married but Marian equal or
higher, which is a man of consequence.
And so she's,
she's,
she's working out all these arguments
in her head that I wanted to,
to offer to you as an audience.
And on the one hand, she's,
she recognizes that she's in this
very strong position. You know,
she is this woman who is both free,
um,
as a female and as a, as, as a slave,
a female because she has money in
a slave because she's been, um,
taken into a family that has allowed
her not to be a slave, um, and,
and decided to honor the, the, the
side of her, her bloodline that, um,
did not emanate from slavery. But then
on the other hand, wanting to belong.
She's talking about this pressure of,
but who will society think I am if
I don't marry a man of consequence?
And then she's realizing also the
ridiculousness of this pressure because it
would be like,
I'm a free man,
begging free negro begging to
be, to have a master, you know.
Exactly that. Exactly. And I, you know,
in the end when you're working
with characters speak to
you and they come to you
with their own story and you know,
there are times where I would come out
with stuff and I go, oh, that was clever.
Oh, I like that. Um, and that, that was
one of those moments where, you know,
so many of the of what comes out
in this story is, um, you know,
comes directly from my own family
and my own love connections in live.
Like, um, you know, uh, what is
right can never be impossible.
It was something my dad used to say
very regular knee or, you know, uh,
when her blood father says to her,
biological father says,
you will not understand this in this
moment, but know that you are loved.
You know, that was something my father
used to say to me when I was very,
very small when he was trying to
give me the steel to go out into the,
into the world. And even lady
Mary's line of, you know,
Elizabeth wait for no man was my aligned
from my big sister. She was sick,
is six years older than me and she
used to try to be the grownup woman.
And so she used to say to me, you know,
you should never wait for any man.
I'd be 10 years old. Um, but
the, these particular lines,
um, would, we're, we're really
lines that for me just, just,
just came from being in the shoes
of the character and uh, yeah,
these things in the story. Okay.
So I, we see a few people in mind.
I take a [inaudible], my
name is Lauren. Hi Lauren.
Thank you so much for coming today.
Um,
I had the chance to see the film
yesterday and it was beautiful. Thank you.
Thank you for making it. Thank, I
have a quick question for you. Um,
my question is what made you decide to
make the film more lighthearted and about
romance versus a darker film that
stresses the turmoil of slavery?
Yeah. Well, Lauren, I
think, I mean for me,
I definitely wanted to,
to create this Austin s drama that I
talked about earlier and challenge myself
to be able to make a film in that way,
show that a woman of color could do it,
could be behind the camera and do it,
but also that a woman of color could be
in front of the carrot at the camera and,
and, um, appeal to everybody
appeal universally. Now.
Um, as we know, Austin never,
she never talked about slavery.
And if I had gone that route of
making something much harder,
I'd have been coming away from my
idea of creating an Austin s you know,
that working in that Austine
sub genre of movie making.
And so, uh, if for me,
I always knew that I was going to tell
this more gentle story where you wouldn't
actually see stays. But as I
explained earlier, you would,
you would feel the impact of the
horror of what was happening to them.
And I also think sometimes that it's you,
you can communicate to an audience
more easily when you're not,
when the horror is
emotional and psychological,
but is not kind of so
explicit on the screen.
And I like to think that I don't
come to movie making with a message,
but I come to ask questions and to try
and motivate you to as a society to,
to, to have those conversations
and ask those questions.
And I think what a costume
drama like this does is,
is inspired conversation and dialogue.
Um,
because not everybody reads wants to read
the newspaper or wants to wants do you
kind of be hit over the head with a
message or a political kind of stance in
that way. But I think it comes to
you in this gentle form. You know,
you naturally respond to it as opposed
to feeling like you're being forced to,
to respond to it.
And so I wanted to challenge myself
and see if I could really tell what is
essentially still a tough story, but
within the context of a love story and um,
self awakening and a journey
towards self love, um,
and not be explicit with violence.
Thank you. Yeah. Congratulations.
Or seeing your vision through.
It's beautiful. Thank you.
And thank you very much.
Thank you. Hi, I'm
[inaudible]. My name is Jana.
Hi Matt.
Like I said,
I actually saw this at tiff and got to
witness and be a part of the standing
ovation. So thank you for coming to
Google. Thank you. Um, so my question,
I'm really interested in
black protagonists and I
read a lot of articles, um,
more recently about black
renaissance and film. Um,
bell is a part of the films
that are named, um, including
12 years of slave, uh,
the Butler Django. Even, um, you know,
some of the argument people are with this
is a black renaissance where as I read
other articles that kind of
discredit this and say, um,
all of these films are most of
them focus on blacks. But you know,
in a space of servitude or,
you know, not modern black, um,
you know, there's a, there's a disparity.
And so I want to know your thoughts.
Bell I think is different because she,
you know, she's, it's a historic piece,
but she's not in a position
of servitude necessarily. Um,
but I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the larger argument of a, this, you know,
this presence of blacks on screen,
but also then being in the past.
Sure, sure. Well, you know, I'm, I do like
to think that bell kind of steps away, uh,
you know, outside of that argument
to a certain extent. So, um, I do,
I do agree with you there.
Um,
but I do think that as filmmakers, um, we,
we,
and particularly as filmmakers of color
or filmmakers that are putting stories
about people of color on screen,
we kind of have to have the
freedom within a certain, um,
to a certain extent to, to
choose the stories that touch
us, that we want to tell.
Now, certainly I can say that as
a British filmmaker of color, um,
we've been starved of those opportunities
to really tell stories about things
that mattered to us.
So the first thing we're going to do
when we get those opportunities is, is,
is kind of go to the heart of stuff that
matters and you know who we are today.
Um, and, and, and, and
what, in what inspires us,
what motivates us to move forward today.
I mean,
I think has so much to
do with our history.
So why not as film makers be able to
look at that history? Now, you know,
I know Steve McQueen has made other
movies aside from 12 years a slave.
Um, and I certainly have made
other movies aside from, um,
you know, this movie bow and I intend
to go on and make movies of all kinds.
In fact, the next movie I'm going
to make us for Warner brothers,
it's called unforgettable.
It's very much rooted in today.
It has a double female lead.
He's very much about, again,
the woman's experience looking
at many of the themes of bowel,
but it much more in a modern day context.
And I have no doubt that many of
the filmmakers whose films we've,
we've talked about, you
know, the Butler, I mean,
you know what was precious if it
wasn't, um, today and though, you know,
the lead character in that movie
had a very, very difficult time.
She wasn't in servitude.
Um,
but we have to be allowed
otherwise we restricting, you know,
US restricting ourselves as people of
color is no different to other people from
other races restricting us.
You know,
just because it comes
from us from the inside,
it doesn't make it any better or any
more, right. Or any more worthy. Um,
what we have to be allowed
to do is a teller stories.
They have to be more of us so that there
is a variety of those stories. Story.
If you've only got five or six of us,
you're always going to be able to,
so comparisons between our movies when
you have, when you have 50 about us,
then you're going to be able to, I
mean, what was spike Lee doing? I mean,
what does spike Lee been
doing for all these years?
He hasn't been telling stories and people
of Color in servitude, can we, you know,
we,
we don't have to,
we don't have to go that far
back to eliminate these stories.
So the arguments for me are, are
unfair. I'm worried, unwarranted.
And I think they're restrictive
and they restrict creativity.
To be honest with you,
we have to be free.
I didn't tell bell without knowing
that I had a responsibility.
And I can tell you that I, I took that
responsibility very, very seriously.
And that is why, despite
the fact that I had, um,
a lot of worries and concerns that she was
too feisty and you know, and, and, and,
and had development was,
was kind of too upfront for me.
I was not going to come to a story. I was
not going to put a character on screen.
And she was that because,
you know,
they were worried that she wouldn't
be likable. And I said, you know,
what's not going to be likable is a week
flower woman of color put on the screen
at this particular time.
Um,
and so I take that responsibility
seriously and is filmmakers of color.
We know how to do that, but we also have
to be allowed to be creative, I think.
Well, thank you for inspiring the
next generation of filmmakers.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thank you. Oh, I have one more.
Hi, I'm uh, my name is Phineas. Hi.
And I just wanted to ask if you had any
pieces or scenes that you had to take
out that you know, you to
want us to know, I guess, um,
it will be interesting to kind
of hear about those times.
Well, early on from the script,
um, I had written a scene,
uh, this is, this is not
a very serious thing,
but it's just the scene.
I would have loved to have
shot where I had written, um,
one of the very typical ballroom scenes
that you get the quintessential ballroom
scene in the period
drama. And um, you know,
again, I'd never seen a woman
of color in that context,
so I really wanted to shoot the typical
dance 18th century line dance scene that
you get.
And it was a very big seed and you know,
was I was going to be shooting it from
the point of view of somebody watching
from above and uh,
it was just so big and expensive that we
had to, we had to take that scene out.
Um,
I do,
I did create a scene at the
very beginning of the movie,
um, where you see, you
see the painter, um,
putting together a sketch of the girls.
It's actually Elizabeth space. What you
see is the kind of quintessential, um,
English girl coming to the fore
kind of emerging in the painting.
Um,
but what you don't necessarily know is
actually the end of the painting is going
to be something very different,
far more powerful and strong.
We had to take that out
because it was no, uh, it was,
it was just sort of intercut,
kind of credit opening credits scene.
But integrating that with,
um,
Captain Sir John Lindsay arriving to
collect the little bow that was a little
bit bit long winded. So we took that
out. Essentially I was able to keep,
keep the essence of the movie that I
wanted. So while we sliced out lines, um,
we didn't take out too many full scenes
that I thought were really important.
Thankfully.
Um,
I'm a control freak and um,
I've been lucky enough in both movies
that I've made to be able to get what I
want up there on screen. And you
know, it won't always be like that.
I know that employers, I know
that. Um, but for now, um,
this is how it has been night that
you essentially, you know, I got the,
I got what I wanted up there on screen.
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you.
Yeah. Well thank you so much.
It's been such a pleasure. Yes.
Thank you for sharing the film and your
perspective with us. This was great.
And we want to congratulate you on
the success of your sophomore project.
Thank you. And we hope you come with,
with your next project. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Really good.
Nope.
Yeah.